what's going on guys this is Rob and I
know we're a little tardy to the party
here right but ward has reached my ears
a lot of people are talking about
William Jackson Harper supposedly
playing Reed Richards and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now this has since
been debunked right like officially it's
come out and it's been said he's not
playing read but he is an Ant-Man and
wasp quantumania and a lot of people are
wondering who's this guy going to play I
think I know exactly who he's going to
play but let's just say for the sake of
discussion that the Fantastic Four do
appear in Ant-Man and wasp quantumania
what does that look like which by the
way I've got uh drywall on my hands so
just so you guys know I've been
remodeling my bathroom so that's why
it's there but here's the thing in
Ant-Man and wasp quantumania if the
Fantastic Four appear it's actually
because of a theory that you guys came
up with so this idea that you all had
which was really really cool was that
the Fantastic Four film is gonna be
rooted in the idea that it's basically
sliders but the Fantastic Four by
whatever Manner and whatever means
discover the Multiverse and they've been
out there exploring it all this time but
when the Multiverse expanded snap back
whatever you want to call it at the end
of Loki they literally got lost in it
and so the entire basis behind the film
is them trying to find their way back to
the main Marvel Universe to basically
find their way back home which they'll
probably end up doing at the end of that
movie however if that's the case it
presents a fantastic no pun intended
opportunity
for the team to appear in Ant-Man a
wasp's quantumania because along the way
they could end up being ensnared by Kang
or something like that however if the
Fantastic Four do appear in this film it
would be for a very short amount of time
and the reason why is because if they
were in this movie for anything more
than 10 minutes say the amount of time
that Reed Richard spent in Doctor
Strange 2 Multiverse of Madness if it
was anything longer than that it's the
only thing anybody would be talking
about and in fact it would take away or
take attention away from Scott Lang
Danny Van Dyne Hank Pam all those guys
nobody would care about the fact that it
was an Ant-Man movie all anybody would
want to be talking about is the
Fantastic Four so we would get a cameo
at best having said that I don't think
they're going to appear in this movie I
don't think the Fantastic Four are going
to be there and in fact I think it's
officially been stated that they're not
going to be in this movie which leads us
to the question who is it that William
Jackson Harper is playing okay so in
order to make sense of this here's
something that I'm going to do for you
guys and we'll probably end up turning
this into a YouTube short King the
conqueror's history and Marvel Comics is
ridiculously confusing if you don't know
anything about Marvel Comics and it's
ridiculously confusing if you do know
anything about Marvel Comics fortunately
you have me so I'm gonna sum it up quick
fast and in a hurry so here's the idea
behind King Kane the Conqueror was a guy
in the 31st Century named Nathaniel
Richards who discovered the ability to
travel back in time realizing that the
past can affect the future Kang went
into the pass and visited his younger
self in order to ensure his younger self
would make the decisions he needed to
make in order to ensure that he would
become king his younger self rebelled
ended up becoming a Superhero by the
name of iron lad now after that came to
conqueror went all the way back to the
days of ancient Egypt gave himself the
name Rama Tut and tried to conquer the
world he was ultimately defeated by The
Fantastic Four and he was supposed to go
back to the 31st Century instead he
ended up traveling to a realm called
Limbo which basically exists outside of
space and time the quantum realm FYI and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
actually a combination of multiple
places from Marvel Comics limbo the
Negative Zone the microverse even the
quantum realm itself in Marvel Comics
that's all combined into the quantum
realm in the MCU the important thing
here is that in the realm of limbo Kang
ended up making a deal with the
timekeepers and who basically made the
steal in order to ensure that he would
monitor the time stream and make sure
nothing went nuts and that is ultimately
the final stop of King so in effect what
this means is that every time you see
Kane the Conqueror doing anything in
Marvel Comics that is Nathaniel Richards
before he becomes immortus that's
basically what that means right
hopefully that makes sense now the thing
about this is William Jackson Harper I
could see him playing Iron lad and
here's the reason why looking at the
trailer for quantumania The Citadel the
city the kingdom of King if you want to
call it that it's pretty expansive and
it's pretty massive now there's a couple
reasons why this could be the case one
it could be that it was always there and
when Kang basically returned following
the return of Multiverse at the end of
Loki he simply just conquered it or it
could be that he's been there for quite
some time because when he returned at
the end of Loki he basically traveled to
the quantum realm and started building
that whole place up building himself a
kingdom and an army if he's been doing
that he's been doing that for a long
time and if he's been doing it for a
long time he's made enemies along the
way which means he's likely been
grabbing people from across the
Multiverse we know that because in the
Ant-Man and wasp quantumania trailer
there is a point in that trailer where
there is a bunch of Scott Langs maybe
it's different people besides Scott Lang
from across the Multiverse playing
Ant-Man but regardless it is a bunch of
different Ant-Man who are doing
something facing off against some threat
we don't know because it's only a
trailer but that tells us that there
seemed to be more than one Ant-Man in
this location where Kane the conquerors
at because the entire film looks like it
takes place in the quantum realm itself
because of that that tells us Kings
grabbing people from across the
Multiverse okay is likely doing is
exactly what he did with Scott Lang in
the trailer where he goes to them and
then basically makes them an offer I can
give you more time or I can do this or I
can do that and brings them to his side
it's entirely possible he did this with
Wanda like we know this from like
everybody who's basically involved with
the character of Wanda maximoff right
like Kevin feige everybody the whole
nine yards who were like that's not the
end of Wanda's story she's going to come
back it's entirely possible that what
Kane did in that moment when the
mountain collapsed on her is he whisked
her away and was like I can take you to
a universe I can give you a universe
where there's a vision and there's kids
but there's no Wanda because you dot or
maybe you didn't exist whatever the case
is but I can take you there and that can
be your new life I can give you the life
you always wanted all I ask is that you
fight on my side in whatever this
conflict is we know from the entire
basis behind One Division and Doctor
Strange 2 that's a very alluring promise
for Wanda and one that she would likely
take and so as a result of that if you
look at it from that perspective that
what Kang's doing is basically building
up his own dark Avengers team if you
want to call that which is exactly what
he could call it right the dark Avengers
that there has to be an antithesis to
that right a light Avengers or a good
Avengers team and so it's entirely
possible William Jackson Harper is
basically Iron Lab maybe he's some
younger version of Kang out there in the
Multiverse that's trying not to become
his future self if that's the case it's
entirely possible that in this film what
you end up basically getting is Scott
Lang and William Jackson Harper that
basically start the early formations of
the multiversal Avengers team along the
way maybe they grab read Richard to the
Fantastic Four maybe Captain America
when he's putting the Infinity Stones
back to where they're supposed to be is
met by Scott Lang and met by like
William Jackson Harper maybe even Loki
who joins this team and is like we need
your help cap one last adventure and cap
goes on this whole thing and helps to
defeat K it's what I've been saying
would likely happen with Chris Evans
Captain in America for quite some time
because his story doesn't feel finished
it does but it doesn't right he just
kind of rode off into the sunset as an
old man but like there's stories waiting
to be told there of what he was doing
during the time when he put those
Infinity Stones back was he just dancing
with and banging Peggy Carter or like
was there other stuff going on so again
no pun intended the possibilities here
are endless but kind of getting off my
my bit of a tirade here that's what I
would argue is the role for William
Jackson Harper that he's basically
playing what is in effect iron lad a
younger version of Kane the Conqueror
who's trying not to become king and is
actively working against King either in
the Multiverse itself or within the
quantum realm so with that being said
guys let me know what you think about
this down in the comments section thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later peace